Stuart Kimball reading for reviewer
Alessandro Barbosa scorn is designed to
be disgusting the walls of its
labyrinthine Halls are constructed with
twisting contortions of Flesh and its
mechanically complex Contraptions are
drenched in the blood of discarded
carcasses that lay decaying without care
the inspiration of scorn's aesthetic are
familiar but well implemented creating
an atmosphere of languish and disgust
that is maintained throughout however
disappointingly scorn's infuriatingly
unbalanced combat uneven puzzle design
and severely restricted checkpointing
make its setting the least off-putting
part about it
foreign
's most immediate impression comes from
its aesthetic this is textbook H.R Giger
with the artist Flair for biomechanical
structures influencing every biome you
visit in scorn if you watch the likes of
Prometheus recently you'll be quite
familiar with the types of interweaving
fleshy layouts that scorn has in store
with some variety in each new area
preventing the presentation from feeling
stale the gratuitous violence and
frequent body horror is less impactful
however there is some initial shock
value in seeing your arm mangled as a
new key item is seared into it or
watching as a parasite latches onto your
body to slowly rip out your intestines
but many of these actions are repeated
frequently enough that their impact
diminishes over scorn's seven hour run
time scorn's violence isn't memorable
instead it's a disappointing departure
from the well-crafted horror of its
Inspirations wasting the potential of
its alluring aesthetic exploration and
puzzles are at the core of scorn's
gameplay Loop you'll explore a handful
of different constrained biomes during
each of the game's five acts all of
which are large multi-step puzzles made
up of small ones that must be solved in
a specific order most solutions come
about through simple exploration each
space has multiple areas for you to poke
around in but usually only one correct
path to follow meaning you'll regularly
come across multiple dead ends before
arriving at the correct route to take
interactive consoles often let you
manipulate the space too moving around
large objects to complete other routes
that let you progress further into the
biome you're currently in each of these
spaces feel like one big Rube Goldberg
machine that you're slowly activating
one piece at a time and it's satisfying
to see levels fold in on themselves and
click into place once you've got
everything down this is crucial given
scorn's purposeful lack of Storytelling
with only two short cut scenes at its
start and end tasking you with making
any sense of everything in between much
of this exploration is broken up with
smaller mini-game-like puzzles that are
far less engaging however there are a
handful of different kinds although many
of them are repeated in quick succession
which dilutes the already lackluster
impact they have it's not that any of
them is frustrating or annoying to
interact with it's more like they're
just completely uninspiring they're
barely twists on existing puzzles you've
probably played numerous times before
like one that mimics the structure of
the popular board game rush hour where
you're moving objects to create a path
to an exit which is painfully obvious
despite the grotesque aesthetic that
they're hidden underneath it's
disappointing that such a core component
of scorn's gameplay experience falter so
consistently and it's especially glaring
given how gratifying the larger puzzles
are although puzzle-based exploration is
the core Focus scorn does have its fair
share of combat with a handful of
weapons and enemies to slay with them
becoming more prominent about halfway
through the story at first these
encounters are light single enemies are
thrown at you which seem manageable with
the limited Firepower you have the first
weapon you find has a very limited range
and requires a lengthy cooldown after
just two shots while also not doing much
damage making each encounter one that
demands caution this is more frustrating
than challenging though your movement
speed even when sprinting is relatively
slow and the lack of a Dodge makes
avoiding damage a chore that's primarily
because most enemies exclusively use
long range and relatively fast attacks
allowing them to hit you well before you
get in close and they continue doing so
as you scramble to get the required four
or five shots in it feels woefully
unbalanced even in the early stages
forcing many deaths before you can
progress
this alone is an entirely uncommon for
horror games it's normal for many in
this genre to encourage players to
circumvent enemies rather than engage
them it's clear that scorn expects this
too but its combat encounters leave
little room to do so although some
enemies are placed in spaces that allow
you to cleverly find alternate routes
around them many of them appear in
narrow hallways that don't allow you to
get on the other side of them easily
you'll routinely take damage when simply
trying to Sprint past most of the game's
foes which you'll have to do frequently
given the lack of both ammunition for
later game weapons and life-giving
health stations this stretches Beyond
just challenging and Falls squarely into
infuriating territory as many deaths are
a result of an increasingly brutal
Gauntlet of enemies that you were both
ill-equipped to face and nearly
incapable of avoiding worse still is the
fact that at least one of scorn's four
weapons can be entirely missed making
long stretches of the game nigh
impossible to progress through with
encounters feeling designed for tools
that you don't have and cannot go back
and retrieve the increasing number of of
combat encounters highlights how brutal
scorn's checkpoint system is too there
were instances where a death threw me
back multiple steps in an ax overall
puzzle forcing me to redo mundane and
safe tasks and obtain key items again
before tackling the same enemy there's
only a single checkpoint stored at a
time too with no option to manually save
this doesn't seem like a problem
initially but it becomes infuriating
when used in conjunction with the
caching of your total health at the same
time there were multiple instances where
scorn saved my progress while being just
a single hit away from Death with
multiple enemies around the corner lying
in weight the only other option aside
from depending on some luck was to
reload the entire act often meaning a
loss of hours of progress this was
forced upon me when my character clipped
through a wall in the game saved
throwing me back into that unrecoverable
state the restrictive saves an
unbalanced combat combined to make much
of scorn's Adventure a frustrating slog
betraying the initial promising open
hours that emphasize puzzle solving in
atmosphere above everything else even
with the disappointing smaller puzzles
the overarching ones that are the
centerpieces of each Act are satisfying
to slowly put together but not
captivating enough to distract from
their brutally unfair challenges along
the way there's simply too much in scorn
that works to push you away from it
rather than pull you deeper into it
making even its relatively brief
Adventure a difficult one to suggest to
give your time to
[Music]